I get a lot of questions about
automation and delegation what should
you attempt to automate what should you
attempt to delegate the technologies
change they adapt and evolved very
quickly so the tools in the toolkit will
vary but if you understand the
principles then you can choose the tools
and you can certainly do homework to
find the latest and greatest I'll tell
you how I look at this in the simplest
form and one of the frameworks should
sound familiar if you've read the 4-hour
workweek 80/20 analysis I will look at
and I do this in fact instead of for
instance New Year's resolutions I do a
review of my entire calendar previous
year week by week 4 in this case we just
came in to 2018 I'll look at 2017 and I
will make a list in fact two lists of
the 20% of people and activities who
produced 80 percent of my peak positive
emotional states
that's one list the other side the 20%
of people or activities that produced
80% of my peak negative emotional states
and it could be as simple as frustration
and what this will help you to put
together doesn't have to be at the end
of the year is a to-do list alright to
focus list and then a not to do list all
right and I tend to focus on these days
at least taking disagreeable tasks or
distracting tasks and first trying to
automate them with software auto-pay
whatever it might be a repeating
schedule with the TaskRabbit for
instance for physical pickup or anything
like that
perhaps you do that through a UPS Store
that scans and the emails your documents
or risk class mail use technology
whenever possible instead of brute force
with humans right even if they're humans
involves in conjunction with the
technology I'll try to automate as much
as possible first then if we're looking
at delegating which frequently includes
technology again I'll try to remove the
negative as much as possible especially
with repeating tasks that is the lowest
hanging fruit
I will look at my primary projects for a
given period of time and if you have
let's just say four or five projects you
could pursue or that are in play in your
life well I will narrow it down by
asking which of these projects if moved
ahead to the next milestone or if
completed will make all of the rest
either irrelevant or make all of the
rest easier and I've done this in fact
recently the last week then we have a
primary focus this is the lead Domino
that will make everything else easier I
will throw as much at that as possible
so let's just say hypothetically we are
trying to design a website in some cases
you want to throw money at a problem
doesn't have to necessarily be a lot of
money
but throw money at a problem instead of
time time is non-renewable so I will say
go to 99 designs and get 50 different
submissions to brainstorm ideas for a
potential website hire perhaps two firms
and have them all at the same time
working on designs so that I can save
time and move this project ahead as
quickly as possible with as few stops as
possible if for instance I need a legal
opinion all right well I'm gonna look
for a consensus I'm gonna look for gaps
to be filled by different people I will
very frequently have two or three people
work on that at the same time and then
gather their responses again just
quickly and review the not to do list
based on the 20% of activities people
that tend to produce 80% of my negative
emotional states and then the to-do list
based on looking at your list of
projects and identifying the project
well that will make the others either
irrelevant unnecessary to do or easier
that is the lead domino and then I throw
as much as possible at that which does
not need to cost a lot of money and
certainly for me has not cost a lot of
money even when I was I'm not gonna stay
in the poorhouse but really really
scraping by and very little you can
still find ways to do it because there
is talent both overseas domestically end
there are many different types of
software that can help you to smooth out
and simplify process to make them much
more elegant so those are a few of the
ways that I think about automation and
delegation good luck
you